turning to afghanistan this morning a
shooting just outside kabul airport
killed an afghan security guard and that
fire fight also involving american
troops is only the latest in a series of
deadly incidents around the airport
where thousands of desperate people are
trying to leave that country u.s troops
are working on new ways to rescue
americans and their afghan allies ahead
of an august 31st deadline and 20
american planes are expected in kabul
today roxanna seberry reports now from
carter where many of the evacuees are
arriving by air
good morning the german military says
one afghan security guard was killed and
three others injured in today's shooting
it's not clear who launched the attack
on sunday president biden said the
taliban have helped the u.s to extend
the safe zone around kabul's airport to
get more americans and at-risk afghans
inside and he didn't rule out having u.s
troops stay past the august 31st
deadline if needed to complete the
evacuations taliban officials are
warning of consequences if that happens
over the weekend the british military
which along with the u.s controls access
through the airport gates said a
panicked crush of people trying to get
in left seven afghan civilians dead
including a toddler president biden says
around 28 thousand people have been
evacuated over the past several days on
both u.s and coalition aircraft
thousands have been brought here to
al-udaid air base in doha where
evacuations from kabul continue on a
quote significant scale we've been told
we've learned that because of
overcrowding at the air base the u.s and
qatar are building extra facilities for
people to sleep and shower also to help
more u.s forces are flowing in like
crazy one source told me the pentagon
has ordered six commercial airlines to
help with the evacuations they've begun
moving people from places like here in
doha to other temporary sites for cbs
this morning roxanna saberi doha